[Music]
you are watching viewers choice so for
today I picked some interesting games
they were sent by the YouTube viewers
and I'm going to share them both with
the audience here as well as with the
audience online so we'll get started
with the game that was played between
the anonymous GM and well I don't know
if I should read some of these names
because I'm worried you know the names
might sound strange anyway said the guy
so King Kai Mac so bread has white in
this position he's the one well in this
game and he's the one who sent the game
and he said that he is just over 1700
and he played this game he finished this
game in 12 moves so considering that
today we're also going to have for the
people here in class we're going to have
the games you know famous games that
everyone should know I figured that this
is a cool game as well so it's it's kind
of a fast game and he beat the 1900 so
let's get started and see what black did
wrong and and what pattern brad has
chosen to to win this game actually to
mate so II six nothing out of the
ordinary so far
d4 and no d6 now this is something that
you don't typically see played
especially if you know like he said his
opponent was knighting a hundred you
don't typically expect them to play this
way because of course it's very
important to get their control over the
center but some of you who have the
knowledge of
know how chess openings have changed to
time you know that you know hyper-modern
is something that is being played
nowadays let's not say that way like we
don't occupy the center immediately we
try to develop on the sides and then
we're going to attack the center and it
all comes back from nimzowitsch on so
it's not too bad right what kind of
systems could come out of these you know
e6 and d6 what do you guys think yeah
some other like a hippopotamus Pierre
well Pierre typically is not played with
these six you have the 19 f6 but there
are some ideas the black play you know
with g6 b6 basically try to develop
their bishops like that something like
that and then eventually they'll play
with c5 for maybe f5 and it's seems good
alright so far okay maybe it's not the
typical thing but not too bad c4 and now
a little bit surprises really when white
chooses such an active you know approach
you you might want to reconsider your
choices you know you want to try to find
a way to place if I fast so black play
97 93 c6 I wouldn't really recommend
this to anyone you know what do you guys
think is this something that you've seen
in 1900
me neither salt a bit confused and white
what should do I do I mean let's say you
get to play against an opponent who just
thinks that they can not occupy the
center and just push the pawns a bunch
of pawns in the opening without actually
maybe if for maybe a florid work but if
not just development you know like if
somebody plays an opening that you're
not familiar with you should just try to
develop your pieces in a normal fashion
and yeah like of course occupy the
center which is exactly what why did you
play Bishop g5 yeah I'm not sure if this
would be the move that I would choose
93's
a knight of 3m sir is another option of
course f4 like someone in the audience
said so okay but Bishop g5 Queen c7
exiting from the from the pin night of
396 if we try to evaluate this position
what would you say about it or what
would you play here with white to
continue yeah just develop another piece
Castle or you can say yes this night has
been moved twice 97 96 Black has only
developed a queen maybe we can even
consider some attack with h4 you know
because this night this is not such a
great square for the night considering I
didn't castle yet that can cost along
any time you haven't attacked the center
just yet and you are underdeveloped so
this would be really fantastic for a
white I believe and you know I would
consider doing that or maybe you would
consider any of the moves that I have on
the screen like Bishop d3 Queen d2 you
know just to finish the development and
kind of show that you're going to
eventually castle on the Queen side
because certainly something is going to
happen on the King side considering the
black did develop that night there it's
probably the place where he will castle
but our the person bred played the rook
to c1 now I have nothing against this
move it's always nice to place your roof
on the same file as your opponent's
Queen but you're not really utilizing
all the advantages that you're getting
from the fact that black
messed up he's he's not I mean just
messed up the development so it's not a
bad move but by playing rooks you won
you are basically giving up your choices
of castling long so probably you're
either Castle shorter stay with the King
in the center you're you're really not
having a serious threat on the sefa
right so try to avoid in this is this
would be my advice try to avoid making
decisive um yeah a decisive moves that
don't give you flexibility it's always
important to especially if your opponent
doesn't follow the regular path of
development try to make moves that give
you flexibility and various ideas do not
show them exactly what it is that you
want to do so I don't see I don't think
this move is bad it's just losing some
of the flexibility that that white has
v5 what do we think about this move
well but White has the King on castled
as well in the center black needs to
find a way to eventually attack the
center and this is this is a possible
way you know it's kind of waste he has
wasted a little bit of time by playing
he's 65 but it is necessary for black to
attack the center of course there are
some other ways to finish the
development but here because the knight
is in g6 protects e5 we don't really
have tricks to take any five and check
me there or something because you know
we would need to to take any five first
and he's she's protected so yes to say
something no okay
d5 yes this is the natural move that the
white has trying to get the space and in
this position why would you play with
black so you messed up a little bit the
opening but now it seems like you're
getting some old Indian style positions
what would you do
maybe better ask you what would you not
do for sure
don't take right then because perfectly
white has perfectly placed the rook on
the C file for you not to take so then
what what should we do with black Bishop
e7 yes certainly I mean or h6 it's up to
you if you want to trade a bishop or
chase this bishop away first
you know the bishop would go back and
then Bishop e7 for example and okay
you've lost a little bit of time but
somehow you know you're getting a pretty
nice position and if white takes here
with which piece would you consider
capturing back
to control that square normally we would
like to take with the night and place it
in d4 but here you might want to avoid
95 so with a pawn and the fact that the
rookies on the C file doesn't really
help white very much right he was unable
to actually open up the file for the
rook
so now white will have to find a way to
bring the rook on the D file but anyways
white is not really forced to take right
white can finish the development but so
here like I said like aged six Bishop e7
is probably what I would consider to
play with black but in this position
black played c5 so already two moves
down is sixty-five sixty-five this
cannot be good this cannot be good so
what did I do
now it's about utilizing the fact that
the king is in the center but you don't
actually utilize it because the file is
open but you utilize another typical
idea this diagonal so somebody said
night night good night b5 and here black
made it pretty easy he played Queen d7 I
mean it's it's a very very difficult it
probably was a very painful loss for
black because I mean you you already
moved so many pieces and now you're also
putting the Queen in front of the bishop
I mean this is just not right I'm not
saying that after this black would have
been okay but at least you keep your
bishop open I mean you cannot play with
no space and also restricting the only
space that you have for your bishop
probably Queen a forward that followed
but now you can play Bishop d7 and and
not lose to too fast but black play
Queen d7 white finish the development
Bishop d3 and in this position black
kind of blundered well small mistake a
six
what do we do
say again please Queenie for and well
that is a pin you cannot take my night
and what is my threat mate mate and it's
matric so you you really have no no
chance of actually stopping the mate and
stopping the capture of the rook - maybe
you could have taken the night but black
plate aged six year after night c7 the
game was over so it was a pretty I found
this a really nice game so I thought I
would share it but it clearly shows why
should why you should really be
respecting the principles or if you're
trying to play something different some
modern type of opening try to still
respect the principles I mean there's
still this idea of development you
cannot really do what you want and
expect to get a good position so you
know and as you could see it took a
really long time for Y to actually get
into a winning position why it was
better all the way but it wasn't until
black played c5 that the position got
pretty bad so you can sometimes survive
by making a lot of mistakes but yeah
pretty bad most of the pieces there and
this night in g6 didn't turn out to do
very much well hopefully you enjoyed
this game let's save it in case some
point we'll use it for something so we
have some other interesting games let's
go for this draw this is a pretty
interesting game Oh do you know do you
know whose game this is or do I really
happy that it's a draw the draw okay
well so I'll just leave this here for a
second to read what our viewer said so
he said I would like to submit this game
for if you are playing with the white
pieces against my friend who is an
average of 300 yellow above me since we
first met so he says he's been working
on his drawers but okay this one this
game still turned out to be a draw
and it it was a pretty interesting game
so let's get started with it I'll put it
on training so we can get to guess some
of the moves
okay so g3 so okay by the way you didn't
say the name so it was played between uh
nice and cat girls something journey
okay
g3 d5 Bishop g2 96 somehow it turned out
that for today some of the games were
you know modern but that's ok and you
know I want to show that it's possible
to play these types of openings you just
need to make sure you still respect the
principles 9 of 3 e 5 what do we do here
with white well if you play this you
need to be careful for this move so
typically d3 but in this position white
played III d4 is another option but d3
typically is something that the right
place will get ready
style position or reverse Kings Indian
kind of so or modern ok white played III
why is this kind of dubious choice
because yeah I mean you know Black has a
threat we have to always consider what
our opponent wants to do including the
openings especially in the openings and
especially in these types where there
isn't a clear theory or well in this one
there is but okay so III see 494 Knight
takes d4 now this move although it does
give blacks some kind of you know maybe
edge say because white gets the pawns
doubled these pawns are not really weak
so you have to always consider am I
really weakening my opponents pawns or
it's just a trade like any other and
here this is not a weakness in by any
means because white will always have the
option to play d3 and trade the double
pawn and everything will be fine
so if black wants to keep some advantage
here 95 is in my opinion a better choice
because this 19 d4 is going to be chased
away later so black will try to get a
little bit more space and we did chase
away the knight from from the King side
so I remember when I normally play
bullet or or blitz online I did lose a
lot of games because at some point you
know I had the pre move and I forgot to
push the three and I would either lose
my knight because I forgot and I would
try to castle or I would allow these h5h
pores and and sometimes I would lose but
here we're not talking about that you
know those are just for fun I really
would like to mention that but anyways
these are good positions for black but
in this game black took in d4 pawn takes
Knight f6 what do you do white
castle of course finishing the
development Bishop e7 93 I probably
would have gone for d3 immediately
considering the fact that there is no
bishop in a5 that would stop me from
capturing back with the Queen but Knight
c3 was the move played by white Bishop
e6 these are some other interesting
ideas that that I've seen played
previously they don't always get give
you black a lot of play but still it is
annoying when when you're kind of forced
to play Queen e1 and it's just a
development move with tempo 10 Queen d7
can can be played for black and you can
try to trade the bishop so you made a
development move with tempo you
typically like to look for those kind of
things but black just chose to develop
the bishop quietly in six of course you
have similar ideas but now you're not
forcing way to move the Queen d3 now
Bishop g4 f3 what do you think it was
this a nice choice by white or should he
have done something else
or maybe it was she maybe there are two
girls I'm not quite sure from the names
maybe what do you guys think maybe I
should say she instead of him okay
doesn't matter
so Queen Dido yeah maybe so that you can
take with the Queen yeah but if three is
interesting choice to because white is
trying to open up the bishop but the
bishop was going to be opened up a new
is this way so that's why I would
probably go for Queen d2 but f3 was the
move played and Bishop c8 it's not such
a great choice by black right
considering the rating which black hand
here 1566 this is not the type of move
that we want to play what should like do
of course just simply take leave those
two pawns double they are not weak but
at least they are doubled and so you
will have a majority on the on the King
side where's White's majority on the
Queen side will be kind of blocked
because of the double points this is
this is a typical idea that we
encountered and normally in real apes'
well in the exchange variation of the
real offense Bishop takes c6 in black
normally has the messed up majority okay
Bishop takes f3 Bishop a oh sorry there
was my line what I thought blacks should
do and now you can go back if you want
or you can trade the bishop either one
depends whether you want to attack or
not but in this position black play
Bishop c8 so what did why do
take with the deep one of course now we
have a little advantage with a pawn up
so what is starting to get a better
position right so it was pretty good our
viewer or well the person who submitted
the game certainly was happy in this
position with the extra advantage and
was able to even get more advantage but
unfortunately it was not able to convert
the game so let's continue and see what
happened
'if I like this move because you're
getting more space and you can certainly
consider some attack on the kingside now
that you have also an extra pawn and 9
f8 next move what's your next move for
YB
f4 is an option and if you don't want
this post to be doubled for some 92 are
you 192 yeah maybe because he doesn't
have space yeah that's interesting yeah
Queen d3 was my the move I was thinking
about but 92 might be nicer because if
black tries to play this French type of
style with c5 you have c3 right so okay
but f4 was played so going for the
attack not caring about this I mean we
take back and then this Bishop can be
developed here of course and then we
also have the same kind of idea with
Queen D 3 and C 4 black play 97 H 3 o to
be surprising if you want to play d4 you
can just go for it right now so didn't
quite understand this move h3 Castle 92
preparing some stuff but also this
Knight is always nice I always liked
positions where the opponent didn't have
so much space and it wasn't so clear
where the bishops would go so you have
sometimes maneuvers that you don't let
them take your knight anymore and just
bring them on the other side like if
white ever plays a5 you can bring the 19
f4 or or if you if you push g4 you can
also bring it here so depending on where
you want to go next
h5 or try to put pressure on d5 that's
all those ideas I love them for some of
you who are familiar with the benoni
White has plans to bring this night from
f3 to D to C for right those are nice
ideas because you are you are not
allowing black to play Bishop g4 and
take your knight and you're bringing the
knight to put some pressure on this six
and and sometimes stop-stop ideas would
be 5 but okay those are other openings
for another time
c5 c3 Bishop a5 Bishop d2 now we can
really tell the fact that you know white
was not a very strong player but what I
like about it is that he or she did
follow the development patterns did
finish the development but not Bishop d2
you know if you want to develop this
bishop you need to try to be a little
bit more active this is not such a nice
place where you're actually stopped by a
pawn of course if you're thinking that
your opponent after Bishop d2 your
opponent would take in d4 right you take
back then that Bishop will be traded or
finally will have a diagonal that's a
wishful thinking only you know you you
cannot think that way in chess you need
to consider some better choices for your
opponent and right you can take us it's
a free pawn you can take it if you want
but if not if you want to develop the
bishop more like here will be the place
and you're not worried about Knight a5
because the bishop goes to f2 because
your pawn is up the bishop in f2 is
that's a famous type of idea that you
encounter from King's Indians right your
Bishop gets to retreat and and then you
start pushing that night back g4 f5 you
know so d2 is a little bit too passive
Black was very nice to take and white
chose to take with the knight but of
course this was another option to try to
actually get rid of the bishop but maybe
white thought okay black has less space
I will not trade the piece I could not
tell you exactly what what was White's
idea and I takes the for rugby eight
what is blacks plan after a bit I think
it's kind of
clear try to push the pawns on the
queenside create some plan I mean it's
tough when you're playing with a pawn
down but you need you cannot give up you
should never give up in chess your
opponent can always make mistakes
so look f3 yeah immediately
yeah this is nice
yeah because now you have f6 yeah and if
I play off six what do you do yeah I can
push you six and then go with this pawn
you also have Bishop f4
yeah maybe immediately of five would
have been uh
it's pretty it's a pretty tough position
for black rook F 3 is a little bit
strange but why does prepare for the
attack b5 now before f5 once again of
course
we are often tempted when we see that
our our opponent is attacking on one
side of the board we're often tempted to
stop them they think you have to figure
out where on which side of the board you
are attacking recently I play the game
where my opponent was going to attack me
on the kingside and I was going I had a
really big advantage on the Queen side
so I started there and for some reason I
panicked and I thought there will be
some attacking idea on the Kings side I
should stop it but instead of stopping
it I actually weaken my king more when
you're when you are the one attacking on
the Kings side and your opponent attacks
on the Queen side I mean let's just say
King side is already you know castle so
let's assume that you really don't need
to do too much on the Queen side you can
just go on with your attack unless you
see that you're going to lose some
material because you know if your attack
works and you make the right moves
towards improving it and make it work
you're going to finish the game much
faster than they are on the Queen side
because typically how does it happen it
they are taken they try to come you know
around because they cannot play on the
side that you're playing so yeah before
it's a little bit of it's not really
necessary so it will help black a little
bit get the bishop on a better position
and then play a 5 but still it's not a
mistake because after Bishop b6 Bishop
e3 white still has the plan with that 5
it just needs a little bit more time now
you know because of course because of
the pin we cannot push up 5 so we have
to protect it first and now we can still
not play a 5 we need to probably play d4
and then a 5 so
it basically slowed white down yes yes
twice two or three moves in a row white
could have played a five but now it's
not so simple anymore
Bishop f2 so it is possible that our
viewer was familiar with Bishop III
Bishop f2 idea but maybe thought the
rook should be placed better in f3 which
I don't really agree that the rook is
better placed in f3 what do you do with
the rook you need flexibility when you
have rooks and you either are going to
push the f1 and make you look really
flexible like be able to come attack or
you keep it in f1 because you will be
placing it in e1 and maybe play six and
open up the e-file but this way is a
little bit strange but black could play
a five year yes and
no I'm thinking to actually take rook
takes and now maybe I can push
or Quinn somewhere first maybe I can
just push you for
I have ideas with Bishop h4 I just need
to make sure nothing will happen because
of this pin maybe King h1 some point is
helpful if I want to attack the Kings
that I can still go for it yeah
but black play Bishop d7 finishing the
development G 496
now again f5 wait f5
yeah Knight takes upon
but rook d3 you know white change the
plans first it look like they are going
to plan the Queen's the kingside
attacking and now is going back for the
weakness in d5 you need to kind of make
up your mind what is it that you want to
do here it happened to have word but in
other cases switching plans like this
for no specific reason is not such a
great idea
so Knight takes d4 Bishop takes Bishop
e6 f5 very good and now Queen e2 now
this is a permanent weakness for black
of course it's been there for some time
but now white is going to try to still
improve the position of their pieces
before taking it this was of course not
a possibility and thanking somewhere
just you know your when you know you're
going to go for a pawn and open up
diagonals and things you need to make
sure your King will be safe and with the
push of these pawns it doesn't I mean
it's still winning for white it just
it's not the right way to go because you
can give counter play to the opponent
and that was the reason why eventually
in this game white did not win
so Queen e2 rook e8 of course creating
some threats and now Queen f2 and this
is a mistake
Queen e3 was a better choice why did not
realize that this pin could not be in
their favor so you have to play Queen e3
because the Queen here you know stop the
pin there but also keeps this pawn
protected and also you know offers the
same thing as with the Queenie enough to
some trades in b6 and white having an
extra pawn is going to go for an endgame
where he will not have to worry about
their King anymore because if we trade
Queens and way when this pawn will have
two extra points nobody will get to our
King tomatoes but after Queen of two
white allowed the capture in e5 which
black took and now it's not so easy
anymore Queen a for now Bishop takes b6
was another option rook takes and now
what can I really do with the white
which one Luke takes the Pfeiffer Luke
do you wanna hear some roopd 165
Bishop tags I'm assuming right
to be careful for someone entrances here
and your King didn't raid Queens yet you
can survive but why why allowed this you
know you can just click windy for just
take that point only when you know that
you're not going to give too much too
much country play for example if black
plays you key to here what do we do with
white
let's take the porno because now the
Queen's get traded off the board and the
other hook will not be able we will not
let the other route get on the
second-ranked anyway so my line that I
had here at Queen D for Queen c7 and now
just take the pawn and I think white
still has a big advantage the Queen in
d3 proves to be a nice piece right now
because it controls the GC g 3 square so
blacks queen will not be able to create
any threats for the moment but in the
game after rook takes e5 white played
Queen f4 going for this kind of skewer
but unfortunately you know it's not so
simple because if black would have
played Queen c7 there's no threat like
you cannot actually take the rook it's
just it's just one threat but we can go
king each one and then we're threatening
the rookin eventually that point will be
gone we also still have some f6 ideas
but ok not as strong as before but still
pretty nice ideas in this position after
Queen F for black blundered and white
took the rook of course it is not over
things have changed so this proves to
everyone that you should first you
should never give up and also when
you're winning you need to focus even
more than before because it's in those
moments that you can lose it you know
and and although I teach you so all the
time don't think that it doesn't happen
to me too actually recently I played the
game and I was winning and I thought
everything is fine and I just blundered
something so went from winning to losing
that's that's very painful so when
you're winning you have to give it your
best shot to to actually you know
convert the position Bishop g7 and like
I said white blunder here we shall be 6
you know I don't know what was in
in in our opponent in our viewers mind
right we should be six is just giving a
material after Queenie eight there's not
so much the black can do because
obviously this is not this is a great
idea but you're just giving up material
easily right don't want to do that and I
don't see any ideas that black could
have that actually would work I mean I
can also take here next and right it's
over it's an extra rook but white
blundered so it's fun to see these games
I don't know how how fun it is for you
guys I hope it is there's no way fun
because you know you're you are
depending on your level you see some
stuff that maybe you wouldn't do but
then there's still things that you can
learn so anyways
Bishop b6 Bishop takes with check King
h1 and now black played Bishop h5 I
think sorry punished five Bishop c7 of
course was was something else that black
would do and now you have that Bishop at
least and still after Queen eight you
have to to be careful not to play Queen
t6 but you can you can now maybe play h6
or something
it's still pretty bad well as you can
try black played h5 trying to open up
somehow like this maybe rook takes d5
Quinn there look f1 there's no threat
don't be scared by ghosts there's no
threat here just Queen takes b6 a free
piece that the black is giving away and
why I want this bishop and not the other
one because I want my queen to make sure
that you know I'm not scared of of
attacks or whatever could happen here or
perpetual check nothing is going to
happen
for example if black takes here what do
we do just check and trade the Queen's
and it's over very simple
rook f1 white got scared for some reason
rook e1 well you know like just look for
threats
look what because often your opponent
will not resign in a lost position so
what you need to do is make sure that
they actually have something serious
like some serious threats if not just
you know player game go for the material
go for the mate whatever but but you
know don't don't get don't get freaked
out because you know I mean even if
you're playing against a strong player
there's this tendency that you know when
somebody plays against somebody who's
let's say three four hundred points more
you think they calculated everything if
you see something and you know you don't
see a way for your opponent to actually
counter that just go for your go for
your line I mean go for your line okay
maybe they did see more than you but
typically you know we're all we're all
making mistakes so it's just a matter of
time
okay rookie one white took which is of
course a great thing now we have an
extra rope all we have to be careful for
is to make sure the black doesn't have a
perpetual or some mating idea which they
don't but white instead of trying to
actually I shouldn't have press the
button but here we look at this King
right and it has no place to go and we
just need to find a way to attack it
does black have anything the only thing
that they have right now is capture the
rook with Czech Bishop text and then
they need to play Queen g3 or Queen f2
to actually have a threat right so
there's no direct threat besides this
check which is not actually a big thing
so we have to think about how to get to
that king this is the most beautiful way
to do it
f6 you open up your rogue and it's going
to be over because if black plays g6 for
example what do we do but if you're
really scared if you're really scared
let's just save this nothing nothing
hanging
but instead why play this move which was
kind of strange queen bee ate and now
things went south because check queen f2
and what do you do because obviously
this queen h2 does not work because
you're gonna get mated so this is the
only move but now it went from white
winning two black winning or draw
I mean black has draw but I think but I
can actually try to play for a win
check Queen have to check King h1 takes
the rook of course and in this position
I I really think if somebody wants to
play for black before win it would be
black because your King is messed up and
I will always have checks in such a way
that I'm going to win at least one but
probably two of your pawns and so
basically here white got lucky lady
takes h5 I mean if you want to try to
save yourself maybe you should try some
Queen b7 but how how does what how does
black continue here which one would you
would you take would you take this one
would you go for this one or would you
take here
beep on okay and then if you take the
beep on don't you worry that I'll take
the F pawn and then have at least
perpetual I think you should go for this
one yeah I came here because now you
take with a check with check and if they
want to play Queen G - what do we do
tricking and pawn and game should be
winning because you have your postponed
on the Queen side so Queen g3 and now
this is nice check and now
guys look at this king it has no exits
yeah well actually Queen a4 immediately
does not yeah yeah that's that's the way
very queen g3 first because now you want
to take in there and if I push h4 for
example then you can go there I have to
if I have to play this move it's very
painful you know I mean you want your
Queen to be active give checks capture
material if you have to retreat just to
save your team yeah yeah this just
should be over soon very soon so this
would have been a nice ending for black
but black here didn't go for that pawn
well white also took in h5 but still
Queen a1 Queen e2 you want to try to get
as many points as possible instead black
gave this check and took that one look
in a queen and game you have to try to
get the points that are going to give
you the most active ideas or you're
going to try to create a passport for
yourself basically here if we look at
this position if we look at white pawns
on the King side these pawns are messed
up and white cannot create any kind of
threat with the pawns this way only if
white manages to take the point in f7
then they will have some ideas at least
perpetual right or some f6 h6 stuff and
I really have something
but these pawns do not threaten black so
black should go for those because then
they will have the passed pawns that are
going to be to be threatening white so
this is this was not such a great idea
yeah yeah yeah so just like here it's
not so simple to get all of them with
check but that's why that's why Queen a
one was was necessary because now I can
try to go to go up and
you won't be able to actually take them
with check I think or maybe you can if
you if you try to give a check like here
maybe and then if I go to on anywhere in
the first rank there'll be queen bee on
taking the pawn if I go somewhere here
for example maybe you can go this way
and then yeah maybe I'll be able to
actually get the pawn
oopsie but black was pretty nice took
this pawn now queen a4 retreating Queen
e2 but now King g3 if you go for that
pawn which black did White has a draw
check and that's how the game ended so
you know white played a really nice game
with an advantage and everything and
then at some point something happened
they got scared failed to convert a mod
a completely winning position with an
extra route and that was it so I think
this these were nice games that we saw
today hopefully you enjoyed them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]